[Music]
hello peter
[Music]
what have you done with my machine
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know what machine
do you want to play games
cats
[Music]
don't worry ma'am i'm coming
[Music]
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life is felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby doo this crap you know all
this is kind of your mess i know a
couple of magic words myself starting
with the word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another way there
is
a danger to our universe
you know how to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]
so
[Music]